the
argument here is that the policy
in the u.s in particular the policy in
the u.s
appears to be to basically
convalesce in place if you contract
covid
until you are sick enough to go to the
hospital at which point we deploy
various remedies and the position that
this
journalist takes is that in fact this is
an absurd response because what we have
which americans are largely unaware of
is a large
uh body of information
about treatments that are highly
effective at reducing
harm both preventing people from getting
coveted
and reducing the harm when they do get
covered and that this has somehow
fallen by the wayside and i will argue
that this is because
what we have is a system in which our
narrative surrounding everything
has been politicized and
that this has resulted in basically
a run-of-the-mill kind of corruption
that
causes the narrative to be bent to
various people's
desires and this is not only affecting
our discussion
about vaccines which we will get to
shortly but it is
directly affecting both the policy
surrounding when we treat people in
other words do we wait till you're sick
and have to go to the hospital
or do we treat you up front and
basically the argument is
if you're somebody very important you're
going to get medical treatment right
away
we will treat you with things that work
and
you will miraculously have a mild case
but if you are
a commoner you will get very very sick
before that happens or you will recover
and so the argument here is that
remdesavir which is the
uh gold standard in standard channels is
actually
not a very effective drug at all it is
um at best mildly effective reduces the
course of infection by a couple of days
but it's expensive it does have that
going forward it does have that going
for it
uh um as
irvermectin uh ervermectin a vermectin
it
appears to be highly effective
it is a drug with a long safety record i
was going to read
so yeah i've got i have a couple here
that i wanted you want to read something
yeah
maybe it won't be the same thing you
would found but maybe it will be um
so you can show it if you want zach you
don't have to um just a
one paragraph early on not directly
related to what you were talking about
but this fixed fixed narrative has led
youtube twitter and facebook to practice
a new and insidious form of censorship
under the dictum that emerging studies
are fatally flawed and fostered by
fringe elements uh quote there's no
evidence that ivermectin has been proven
a safe or effective treatment against
covet 19 declared an associated press
fact-checking article
similar reports regurgitate government
pronouncements that journalism at its
best
ought rather question and then down
below
we have this section on evermecton three
paragraphs i'm going to read
in a 20 excuse me in a 2011 article the
scientist who discovered ivermectin in
1975
in a patch of japanese soil satoshi
omora
called it astonishingly safe and quote a
wonder drug
akin to penicillin and aspirin after
more than 25 years of use a review in
the journal of drugs and dermatology
concluded
if vermectin continues to provide a high
margin of safety
but the u.s federal excuse me but the
u.s food and drug administration seems
bent on ignoring both safety and
efficacy findings
in a q a on avermectin the agency lists
side effects from nausea and swelling to
neurological events and liver injury
flcccc president dr pierre corey
described the list for me
as quote purposefully alarmist indeed
despite more than 40 positive studies in
avermectin for kovid
the fda seems stuck in a time warp its
website calls the australian study from
eight months ago recently released while
still declaring without acknowledging
newer studies
that additional testing is needed that's
fine if only there was support
just three studies in ivermectin are
preceding the united states and none is
funded by the national institute of
health or any other us agency
yeah i find this absolutely stunning um
here's another section i thought was
pretty remarkable
for 25 years vermectin has been
distributed free in 19
african countries to control parasites
is it a coincidence that those countries
had 28
fewer covet deaths and 8 fewer cases
than 35
other african nations is it a
coincidence that the 240
million resident uh indian state of
uttar
tardesh which distributes free
ivermectin has a covered
uh death rate that is 1 16th that of the
united states
160th sorry i am reading very small font
yeah
it is um so are those things conclusive
they are not because
you have an uncontrolled environment but
they are certainly provocative
um see there was another section i
wanted to
ivermectin the most promising covet
treatment to date won its developers the
nobel prize for medicine in 2015 and a
place in the world health organization's
model list of essential medicines
since the 1980s with billions of doses
given the drug has cured crippling
tropical diseases
that had devastated african countries
while curbing scabies
lice and protecting livestock and dogs
from parasites spurred by pre-coveted
studies showing ivermectin killed
zika and other viruses australian
researchers last spring
tested the drug in a petri dish where it
obliterated coronavice
virus in 48 hours since then more than
three dozen studies have shown good
results in preventing and treating
covid19 to be sure some of the results
sound too good to be true and are based
on small patient samples
others are available only in online
drafts and have not been officially
published
but 16 studies have been peer-reviewed
and 11 are randomized controlled trials
that compared patients who did and did
not get the drug
so that is all very provocative now it
sure is what
i believe is emerging and i don't know
quite how to cast it has nothing to do
with ivermectin and remdesseviere
uh or vaccines in particular is a more
general malady
where before you do that can we just
finish this off before you go into more
general malady
this paper that you were just reading
from uh links to
this site zach and it is called uh it's
it's just a covet 19 um basically
clearing house site uh which uh is
done anonymously um
let's say i had found
the facts before i don't see them here
um
oh here frequently asked questions about
this site um
says we're a bunch of researchers who
aren't interested in
going public but we are basically just
putting together evidence for a number
of
a number of different drugs that are
currently being used to treat this is
not about
the vaccines it's about drugs for
treatment rather than vaccines for
prevention
and they're they're collated information
on every macdone here shows um
tremendously and i'm not this is a
complicated page i'm not going to walk
us through what it is
um but this this page is still up c19
everymactin.com
uh and you can go through you know
efficacy across lots of studies of
vaptin
vitamin d hydroxychloroquine
zinc and brim desevere which has much
lower efficacy
um but interestingly and uh
fairly appallingly um
what we find is um
[Music]
i now can't find the site that oh here
we go
um twitter suspended the account
that was being used to to basically
publicize this work at covet analysis
on december 27th and there's no
explanation
or response from twitter as to why what
exactly on this page is dangerous
it is a it is a collation of extant
research on a number of possible
treatments for the scourge
that is threatening to wipe out people
and
economics across the entire world what
exactly is so dangerous about this
right and why does twitter think that it
is expert enough to decide whether or
not we are able to look at this and
discuss it
right who the hell are they yeah and so
the site is still up but the twitter
account is not
yeah so you were sorry yeah what i
wanted to argue
is that what we have what we find
evidence for
across the board anywhere where we take
the narrative that we are handed
and we scrutinize it with tools that we
happen to have
because we're biologists right obviously
we're not
epidemiologists we're not virology
specialists
right but the point is basic scientific
literacy a willingness to dive into
these things what we find again and
again
is that the narrative that we are being
handed and the narrative we see being
enforced
on social media is itself garbage and
politicized and one can deduce
what its purpose is by virtue of the
fact that clearly
it is willing to harm people
in order to keep the message simple
and on track in other words why all else
being equal
why would the narrative center around
remdesavir
a drug that has um dubious effectiveness
and systematically shun ivermectin
when the safety and efficacy appears to
uh suggest exactly the reverse would be
wise that that is a preposterous thing
for it to do and the
obvious result is that people will be
harmed right we should be thinking about
treating kovid
treating covet is almost certainly a
good way to prevent people from
communicating covid
and so you know there's no way in which
this is responsible or if it is somehow
responsible
why are we not allowed to have the
discussion that then will inevitably
reach that conclusion because we will
discover the reason that rem death
severe is the right choice
and even if even if these two drugs
impermectin and rem desevere
had exactly the same results in the
variety of research that's been done
with regard to treating symptoms of
coping 19.
the fact that it's irmectin
that has been around um that was
discovered in japanese soil in the 1970s
apparently
and has has been used in millions of
people for
other conditions and therefore has a
decades-long
history of studies of safety of places
where it's not presumably
we should prefer that drug all else
being equal
over a newer one just as if there is
a vaccine that is made in the
traditional style
that is available all else being equal
we should prefer that
over an mrna vaccine simply because
there is no way proclamations from
scientists notwithstanding
to know whether or not the new
technology is safe yet we simply cannot
know right
we the public right we who are united
against
covet and its transmission ought to
prefer that on the other hand there's a
very small group that might have exactly
the opposite incentive oh gee
who could they be well and we see this
all the time in pharmaceutical
development where basically
patent protection expires on a drug and
some new either a new drug that isn't
any better
is introduced because it's patented it's
got a little more
tax week has been made in order to make
these things more profitable
and the fact is this is just a place
where markets do a piss-poor job of
managing
the public health um so anyway we see
this all over the place and you
um so i don't know what the patent
situation
is for ivermecton given that description
of how long it's been around
probably uh cheap and uh
readily you know generics available and
just you know just
one other line of evidence to support
that is if it is really being deployed
at the millions of people level across
africa it's it's probably
not a super expensive drug uh to be to
be producing or to be giving out
excellent point and the other thing is
it has generated
exactly the natural experiments that
would allow you to deduce
pattern in other words the fact that
you've got a bunch of different african
countries you know
i think it was 18 of them had widespread
and 30
some odd that didn't that allows you
doesn't mean that that's
why the 18 seem to outperform the
30-some
but it's a strong indication and that
itself is a testable hypothesis so
there's lots of
there's lots of landscape to look at in
order to figure out what is actually
going on and what it
says about what we should do